yesterday the major news broke the biden
administration is preparing an executive
order to have major agencies go ahead
and look at bitcoin and other digital
assets as a matter of national security
now this shouldn't come as a surprise to
many people obviously this industry has
grown from zero to three trillion
dollars in size there's tons of
implications whether they're
geopolitical financial or regulatory and
of course the biden administration they
want to know what the hell is going on
and what is the impact going to be now
barron's is reporting that this
executive order is going to come out in
the next couple of weeks and it is going
to be directed right at major agencies
saying go do your research find out what
the hell this stuff is and what that
impact's going to be it is a matter of
national security now of course this is
being presented in a very negative light
by the mainstream media i don't
necessarily think that they understand
what's happening here though if we go
ahead and we look at matt devos what he
said is what are the national security
concerns associated with bitcoin
that could be highlighted in that
executive order he said one the impact
to the us dollars global reserve
currency two the lack of trading
granularity as wealth moves around
things are like taxation three the use
in ransomware and four the lack of
fiduciary or legal liability for daos
and other types of entities that are
being created in this new digital
financial system now again these are all
the negative impacts potentially of
bitcoin or digital assets on the world
but i don't necessarily think that could
be the only outcome if we go ahead and
we look at jason lowry and what he had
to say he said the primary national
security concern of bitcoin is mass
capital flight at scale that could be
solved if the united states chooses to
buy lots of bitcoin to front run the
flighted capital how do you start to get
the us to agree to buy lots of bitcoin
you pass an executive order asking the
departments to focus on what it is and
what that impact could be now ultimately
i agree bitcoin is a national security
concern bitcoin is a decentralized open
system anywhere in the world no matter
what country you are who you are what
organization you are you can plug into
this system similar to the internet if
anyone can use it the united states had
a choice we could either say no the
internet could actually help our
adversaries the internet could help
criminals therefore we are not going to
participate on the internet there are
some countries that did that like north
korea and it didn't work out so well for
them instead what the united states said
was this open system is going to be used
both the people that we are allied with
and our adversaries are all going to
benefit from it but let's make sure
leave no doubt that the united states is
the biggest beneficiary of the internet
and that's exactly what we did over the
last 30 or 40 years now bitcoin provides
a second opportunity at the exact same
issue
bitcoin is that open system anywhere in
the world you can plug into it anyone
can use it and both our allies and our
adversaries are going to benefit from it
the united states has a choice will we
simply opt out will we sit this one out
and let innovation and adoption happen
globally without us or will we choose to
make sure that we are the global leader
bitcoin is the most american technology
on the planet it protects your freedom
of speech it protects your right to
financial wealth protects you the
individual citizen from an overreaching
authoritarian government bitcoin is the
american ethos written into software
there's a lot of people who think that
bitcoin is a national security concern
they're presenting this in a negative
light but i agree that bitcoin is the
national security concern the best way
to secure america's future is to adopt
bitcoin to embrace bitcoin and to
encourage every single individual
citizen to become a bitcoiner ultimately
what we are watching play out here is
that the innovative technology forward
countries they're going to adopt it the
countries that have authoritarian
governments that end up violating the
rights of their citizens they're going
to kick out anyone who holds bitcoin or
mines bitcoin they're going to attack a
technology that protects freedom of
speech bitcoin is american bitcoin
embodies every american ethos and
ultimately the national security concern
for america is if we didn't adopt
bitcoin if we didn't embrace it but i
have faith that the politicians and also
the private sector they're going to come
together they're going to realize what
the benefit of bitcoin is and ultimately
they're going to embrace this technology
because they want to preserve the
american ethos and no other technology
does that better than bitcoin